posturas opuestas el reino unido ante el
repunte de casos de kobe 19 el país está
registrando diariamente entre 40.000 y
50.000 nuevos casos y el número de
hospitalizaciones se incrementa
constantemente a medida que la situación
se agrava aumentan los llamamientos para
que el gobierno ponga en marcha su plan
b que reintroducirá el uso obligatorio
de mascarillas en interiores el fomento
del teletrabajo e incluso los pasaportes
de vacunación el gobierno se resiste
bloquea de thatcher estamos observando
los datos con la dedicación que se
espera de nosotros pero por el momento
los datos nos sugieren que debemos pasar
inmediatamente al plan b el ministro
británico de economía anunció sin
embargo un programa de 5000 millones de
libras casi siete mil millones de
dólares para financiar la investigación
sanitaria en los próximos tres años lo
que supone un 57 por ciento más que
antes de la pandemia el gobierno bajo el
mando del primer ministro boris johnson
insistió previamente en que el plan de
sólo sería aplicado como último recurso
en su animo a los mayores de 50 años a
recibir una dosis de refuerzo una
postura que preocupa a los profesionales
de la salud la asociación médica
británica acusó al gobierno de
negligencia deliberada
una asociación médica británica está
advirtiendo al gobierno que van a entrar
en crisis y que necesitan que
intervengan e introduzca medidas más
estrictas y el gobierno les ignora a las
autoridades sanitarias también están
vigilando una nueva su variante del
delta altamente contagiosa que se está
extendiendo en reino unido